on a tendance à l'oublier mais aller aux
toilettes
c'est un luxe selon l'onu il ya plus de
4 milliards de terrier qui ont pas de
toilettes à la maison ici au canada une
personne qui fête ses 91 ans a retiré la
chasse d'eau plus de 230 mille fois dans
sa vie et utiliser beaucoup beaucoup de
papier toilette on se demander à quel
point tous pas qui pèse l'eau sur
l'environnement
[Musique]
ces tensions ont fait la guerre aux
produits à usage sauf peut-être pour le
papier toilette
la plupart des gens considèrent encore
comme un indispensable surtout les
nord-américains le canada et les états
unis comptent pour 5 % de la population
mondiale mais déroule plus de 25% de
tout le papier toilette consommé sur la
planète les américains sont les
champions du monde ils en utilisent en
moyenne trois rouleaux par semaine
chacun ils sont 3 125 millions en ce qui
nous concerne les estimations tournent
autour de deux rouleaux par semaine
environ à 37 millions personnes on
enverrait près de 4 milliards d'euros
l'eau et aux égout
chaque année à cette papier pour faire
le tour de la terre 4800 x
c'est l'équivalent d'un gain que 6
millions d'arbres la matière première du
papier hygiénique c'est la fibre de
cellulose qui provient des arbres
certains s'inquiètent de voir une partie
de la forêt boréale canadienne
disparaître dans la cuvette surtout
celle de nos voisins du sud
c'est ce qu'a dénoncé un rapport publié
en février 2019 part de groupes
environnementalistes mais est-ce qu'on
transforme vraiment des forêts entières
en rouleaux pour tout à fait
un house estime annie des cantons
traduit les planches à partir d'un arbre
ivresse des copeaux on transforme ces
restant un peu puis en papier esquivant
papier doux comme des chatons ce sont
les jeunes arbres feuillus qu'on
retrouve plus au sud
alors on peut pas vraiment dire qu'on
rase les forêts anciennes uniquement
pour prendre soin des douilles est fait
sa musique
si le papier toilette et blanc comme une
girafe albinos parce qu'on blanchit la
pulpe qui proviennent de fibres
recyclées ou non la version recyclée est
généralement perçu comme l'option la
plus écolo mais elle implique sont
l'autre produits chimiques
parce qu'il ya deux langues sur les
feuilles qu'on met au bac il faut la
retirer chimiquement et traiter les
déchets toxiques et sa baisse a alourdi
l'empreinte du papier risques tout en
prêchant en 2015 des scientifiques ont
comparé les cycles de vie du papier
toilette recyclé et non recyclés
résultat c'est l'étape de la fabrication
qui passe le plus lourd sur
l'environnement créé la porte il a
blanchi la chaufferie la transformer en
papier tout se demande énormément
d'énergie d'eau de produits chimiques
dans des proportions assez similaire
pour les deux types de papier c'est
quand on regarde les cycles de vie
complet que papier recyclé se démarque
comme l'option la plus durable par ce
qui permet d'économiser la ressource en
réutilisant des fibres de bois qui ont
connu une vie un peu plus nobles avant
de finir dans la cuvette
c'est presque impossible de dresser un
bilan environnemental chiffrés pour un
rôle aux moyens parce que les contextes
de production varient énormément et
c'est la source d'énergie qui fait le
plus pencher la balance à l'échelle du
pays on compte plus de 100 usines de
pâtes et papiers
si je prends par exemple celle du québec
et celle de la colombie-britannique et
fonctionne à l'hydroélectricité
celle qu'on retrouve en alberta
utilisent les combustibles fossiles il
faut quand même souligner de plus en
plus les pétards cherchent à utiliser
les ressources le plus efficacement
possible malgré tout seul la production
d'un rouleau de papier toilette
nécessite entre 45 et 140 litres d'eau
148 c'est une baignoire presque plein
à moins que j'étais son papier toilette
au compost et finit ses jours déchiqueté
dans l'eau et se retrouve dans une fosse
septique ou dans les égouts municipaux
dans les deux cas ils forment une bourse
mélangeant avec toute notre matière
organique
au canada l'ensemble des usines
d'épuration municipale en génère 800
mille tonnes annuellement et on parle du
poids des boues une fois séchées près du
tiers est incinéré et un peu plus de 10%
est envoyé dans des sites
d'enfouissement
dans les deux cas il ya production de
gaz à effet de serre surtout si on
nationale
on cherche aussi à valoriser cette riche
bout de papier de toilette et de
matières fécales environ 50% et
transformé en fertilisants utilisés en
agriculture industrie des pâtes et
papiers dans son ensemble compterait
pour environ un pour cent de tous les
gaz à effet de serre qui sont générés
par les humains
l'empreinte carbone du papier toilette
occupe une toute petite place dans le
ciel
au final l'emprunt est la plus légère et
celle d'un papier recyclé produit avec
de l'énergie renouvelable et fabriqué
près de chez soi si on regarde notre
petite empreinte à nous tous seuls et
paraître dérisoire dans une vie une
utilisation moyenne de papier toilette
nécessite l'équivalent de trois arbres
environ ce pas la fin du monde
sauf qu'à l'échelle de la planète on
estime que près de 10 millions d'arbres
sont employées dans les faubourgs chaque
année pour les gens qui cherchent à
estomper leur trace environnementale ya
de plus en plus de produits qu'ils
apparaissent sur le marché
on touche au roi joli bond j'ai eu trois
jo donc à vous de méditer sur la
question vous connaissez le meilleur
endroit pour me dit rien
[Musique]
oui dernière chose qui pourrait régler
pas mal de chicanes dans les familles le
papier toilette le s contre l'espagne en
avant ou derrière le kulo je vous laisse
sur une image qui date de 1891 série du
brevet du papier toilette
[Musique]